here's derozan
stops fires
got it oh man
good good good offense right there i
mean bogdanovic did all you could do he
stayed in front of him trying to be
physical with him it's a big stop here
got to get a stop one point game
sumo
[Applause]
let's see if they double team him get
the ball out of his hands
derozan
fires for the lady
does it again
oh my goodness i told you demar derozan
time they didn't double him until he was
in the air adam and it was too late once
he got to his spot it was over look no
double team comes comes late spins back
take that with you
demar derozan is the real deal
you hear the mvp chance and deservedly
so
two-point bulls lead timeout atlanta
demar
with the big shot in the fourth again
he has been the bulls go-to player
all season
37 tonight for derozan
that is now the second longest streak of
35 plus in [ __ ]
watch this here it is again herder was
supposed to come he left zach levine
they weren't even worried about zach
levine hitting the three-point shot they
knew that demar derozan was going to be
the guy so they left zach levine and
said hey you know what you beat us with
a three we're not gonna let demar
derozan hit this shot well he got over
there too late because demar spun away
from the trap he saw it ahead of time
spun away from it got separation and
then got the foul as well what's the
word we used earlier precision
everything about demar derozan is
precise
it may not look it in terms of speed
but he plays at his own pace never and
nobody can rush what derozan can do it
is right there look herder if you're
going to commit if you're hurting you
got to go if you're going to come over
there don't go halfway on demar derozan
have you not been watching demar derozan
all season long this guy has been
killing in the mid-range shot he was
probably supposed to go double right
away and that hesitation allowed tamar
to spin away from it because it was not
an aggressive trap